Okay, guys, I don't think this guy needs an introduction, but this is Mike V, like, to
be honest, I just have, I have nine questions for you, dude.
And Mike V is at $40,000 a month, and he just posted his Stripe screenshot in I think it
was the free group, which I really appreciated.
And because I know sometimes it's scary to share, I know sometimes you think, dude, what
are people going to say?
What are they, you know, it's not even what they think, but what are they going to say?
And if you're not the braggy type, then maybe they're going to think I'm like that.
And so I do appreciate it because I think you'd be surprised how much people really
get inspired by those posts, way more people get inspired than get jealous.
And the people that get jealous are going to just blame the program or me or everything
else and quit anyway.
So it doesn't matter.
But Mike V is at $40,000 USD per month.
And I just want to ask him questions personally about how he got there, what he's doing.
And like, these aren't to fill time.
These are like genuine questions.
So I just want to basically jump right in.
Aaron, I'm going to let you ask any questions you have, I'm going to let you also, if you
guys have questions, start dropping them in the comments, I'm going to have Aaron kind
of moderate when there are questions that when we get to the end.
So Mike V, in 42 minutes, I'm going to let you off the stream.
If you can give us 42 minutes, I would appreciate that.
And we're just going to get through as much as we can.
Is that cool?
100%.
Beautiful.
First and foremost, you guys need to follow Mike V on his Instagram page.
He has two.
And he just followed me on his like business one.
He has some really amazing content ideas.
And by the way, I just saw the most awesome post you made where someone is massaging your
head while you were working and you had someone who touched your feet and like he based it
like six.
I don't even know what what nationality these girls were, but you just look like a king,
dude.
Yeah, it's it's one of the hacks is when you when you're printing, when you make money,
you got the massage, you get a foot massage, you get someone doing your head and you're
just sitting there, you know, checking strike balances, doing SEO makes for a good experience.
Dude, if you're not checking SEO and eating like some type of exotic fruit, you're you're
really not living, you know.
For sure.
That's a good time over here in Thailand for sure.
But yeah, I think things have moved pretty quick this year.
It's been good.
What's your Instagram, bro?
I want to guys, I'm serious.
You guys should get inspired by what this guy is doing.
And yeah, what's your Instagram, your personal or that one or whatever one?
People should follow you should check out what you're doing because this guy is making
moves and he's just getting started.
So what is it?
And then I'll have or I can even have Aaron go go to Instagram, find Mike V and just share
share his link.
I'll do that for you.
Oh, he already did it.
Marcus, we understand the chat.
There you go.
Beautiful.
OK, you can drop me a photo there to see what I'm up to.
And I've also got a link to my business profile and my personal one.
That's OK.
Awesome.
So let's just let's just dive into this.
We've already interviewed you before, so I'm not going to backpedal too much.
But just real quick, tell us when you started and where you're living right now.
When I started digital landlords.
Yeah, when you started the program, I know that you had a little bit of digital
marketing experience. Yeah.
Just when did you start in here?
I started in digital landlords about 26 months ago and I'm currently in in Thailand.
Can you guys still see me?
Yeah, you're back. Can you hear me?
Yeah, yeah.
That we cut out for a second.
OK, we're good. OK, I heard 20.
You said 26 months.
Yeah, 26 months in digital landlords.
At that time, I was back home in my corporate job and we're in Bangkok now.
OK, beautiful.
So that's just to give a little bit of a of a backdrop.
So basically a little bit over two years.
So here's the first question.
Go ahead, go ahead.
Yeah, two two years in digital landlords.
OK. That's crazy, bro.
I was in programs for four years and I was barely scratching 8000 a month.
So I admire people like you, Ryan Dalton, like that.
You guys are able to pick this up so quickly.
I'm the type of person that just takes a long time to learn stuff.
So I love it, dude.
OK, so remind me, because I don't remember when we talked last time,
did this did it click for you right away or did it take you some time?
I know I do remember you getting to 10K relatively quickly,
but like, did that very first deal?
And I'm saying that for the people that just started, like, did it click quickly?
And if so, why do you think that was?
It clicked pretty quickly compared to what I was doing for the previous four years,
because I was trying to figure out how to make money online for four years.
And I was making a thousand dollars a month for four years.
And then I joined the program and I just worked as hard as I could.
And it clicked pretty quick.
I mean, it was pretty tough up until the first deal.
Just trying to believe in it and, you know, having the faith and everything.
But I just, you know, read the book, the Thinking Grow Rich book.
And, you know, once that first deal got over the line,
it was pretty smooth sailing from there.
Like you said, you just need to repeat it, you know, eight more times
or 40 more times or whatever you want.
Why? How long did it take you to get your first deal?
I think it was four or five weeks.
OK, that's maybe six.
I think five.
That's good.
But it's not like, you know, you've got some guys like a week or two weeks.
Like, that's good.
But it's not like overly like that's doable.
It's repeatable for anyone that gets in.
Like, you know what I mean?
Like anybody could come in and get a deal in five, six weeks.
So that this is what I'm trying to figure out.
And the reason I'm having you on, dude, is like,
I'm trying to figure out why it is that some people are so successful.
And why some people
just want to like they it's it's it's the same material.
It's the same program.
It's the same coaching calls.
It's the it's usually the same niches.
But you're at 40K and there's people at zero that are blaming everybody else.
Why do you think there's people out there that have been in for 90 days,
you know, six months and have no deals?
I think they might be comfortable, you know, not kind of want it bad enough.
I remember when I joined, I was already going to quit my job
and and leave the country and, you know, pursue my dreams.
So my back was against the wall.
So I don't really have a choice but to make it happen.
And I knew I knew really deeply what I actually wanted,
like from digital landlords, I knew that it was going to be the avenue
to live the life that I have now.
So I think just understanding exactly why
they'll get you through like the trench phase,
because there's a trench phase to every type of business model
and everything you do, like whether it's learning to ride a bike, close deals.
You have to get through that trench phase.
And that's basically impossible
unless you have like a
why and perhaps like forcing yourself to do it.
And if I wasn't going to quit my job, I probably wouldn't have worked as hard
because I knew, you know, I've still got my my paycheck coming in.
So you don't have an element of risk, I think, to go.
So how do people that because I do know what you're saying.
And essentially what how I interpret that is like when people are
I swear comfort is the scariest thing ever.
Right. Because when you're comfortable, you don't want to do
you don't want to move because it's like you're just
it's like being in your freaking bed and it's cold outside.
Like you're just you're you're you're just content.
You're just laying in those sheets and it feels so good.
But you know, you're going to feel regret and you know,
you're going to feel these things.
But it's so hard to get out because you're comfortable.
So how do you like?
You know, I'm kind of like you, bro, I think, because for me,
that sounds like you had already made up your mind
that you're going to quit your job.
You're going to go pursue your dreams.
That's just what was going to happen.
And so you're going to force yourself to make it happen
because you're going to make yourself uncomfortable.
What do other people do, bro, that aren't that type,
that they're not the type that's going to go quick
because I did that same kind of a thing.
I just kind of quit what I was doing before.
And I'm like, well, I have to figure this out.
So but maybe they're not everyone's that type.
That terrifies people.
Do you think there's a way that people that aren't that type,
that are comfortable right now in a job, in whatever,
that they can force that discomfort without, like, completely just,
you know, throwing caution to the wind?
Yeah. You know what I mean?
Yeah, for sure.
I don't recommend everyone does the same approach I did,
you know, especially if you've got family or something like that
or other commitments.
But I mean, I'm teaching a couple of people,
local business, lead generation myself.
Some of them are in fairly comfortable positions,
like they might have other income at the moment.
And I think what works for those people
is kind of setting goals for yourself each week
and having, like, a bit of a timeline to make your first,
you know, $2,000 to $5,000.
And then once you break that down into, like, weekly KPIs
or things that you need to tick off,
you know, at the end of the week and say,
hey, did I do it or did I not do it?
And I think it just comes down to discipline
as well as a bit of that mindset training as well.
And I'm sure you're still telling people
to read that Think and Grow Rich book.
So I think a combination of, yeah, your mindset
and having the discipline with, like, a set goal,
that's what I'd recommend
instead of just throwing caution to the wind, perhaps.
Okay. I'm writing notes, dude.
And I'm not, again, I hope you can tell,
I have all these questions,
but I'm genuinely, like, having this conversation
like we're just sitting there having the conversation
because I would love, I'm trying to extract
out of your brain how we can,
and sometimes it's hard because for me,
I just do it a lot of times.
And so sometimes it's hard for me to relate to other people
because I've always thrown caution to the wind, dude.
When I got my first sales job,
it was door to door, 100% commission,
with a baby on the way, I was recently married,
I had no money coming in and I was like, yeah, sign me up.
I can make, what's the potential?
What's the best guy?
What was the best guy in the company last year?
They said 90 grand.
Okay, awesome.
So that's the, I can make at least 90 grand.
Okay, sign me up.
I know I'm as good as that guy.
And that's just how I think.
And I quit my job and we moved across the country
and I made it work.
When I started this business, I bought a program
and I stopped doing that job to do this.
And I just, sometimes I find it hard to relate
and I don't know how to tell people
to make themselves uncomfortable because they just,
they're just gonna die in their discomfort, I feel like.
Aaron, do you have anything you wanna add on this?
Because Aaron is, dude,
this is one of the sharpest kids I've ever met.
Very persistent, by the way.
One of these days we're gonna go live
on how persistent this guy is.
Aaron, anything you wanna add on this?
No, I mean, I think you're right on, Mike.
It seems like we always do the thing we desire most
in the moment and just we live life
generally choosing comfort.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
And- Yeah, for sure.
And we trade temporary comfort for future regret,
which is scary.
I don't know.
I think I'd add on that,
just thinking about how to put early,
putting yourself in financial stress
or family stress or whatever is,
just having a true understanding
of the shortness of life.
And I was reading a lot of stock philosophy
leading up to joining the group
and also going home with the travel side
and actually kind of meditating on that a bit
and just pondering the short life
can motivate you in a way of, for me is like,
there's so much to explore in this world.
There's so many places to travel to.
There's so much to experience.
And you can't really appreciate that
until you kind of understand that,
hey, we only really have 80 years here.
So that's another way to kind of motivate yourself
to work harder.
Yeah.
This is a personal question.
You said you would already made up your mind
to quit your job and chase your dreams, right?
Yeah.
What are your dreams?
What is it that you,
because I think people are either motivated
by they're running away from something they're scared of
or they're running towards something that they want.
What are your dreams that you wanted to quit your job
and use this to achieve?
I think you should do it now,
but training Muay Thai, waking up whenever I want.
I ride my scooter through the mountains
to the beach every day.
Got a pool villa with a nice blue pool in it.
I'm hanging out with other guys doing the same thing.
Now I don't have to go to my corporate office
and like sacrifice my authenticity.
You know, I don't have to live in anyone else's shadow
and do stuff that's inauthentic,
which I think can just impact the quality of your life.
When you have to go to a job that you don't like
and supplicate to a boss, like it chips away your soul.
And I'm living my dreams now, so I'm happy as.
That's sick, dude.
So you're living in Thailand.
You basically every day you wake up when you want
and then you, how many times a week are you going
to the beach through the mountains on a scooter?
Every day I drive into Starbucks,
get a coffee, hang out with some friends
and I still work extremely hard.
I think last month I worked 30 days straight,
just because I was so excited about the business
and I had a lot of momentum going.
That's crazy, bro.
I love stories like that.
Stories like yours, they are inspiring
because it's like you are literally,
it's like you're like literally living
the Tim Ferriss 40 hour work week,
not necessarily that's how much you work,
but like just the, you're doing, is it called Muay Thai?
Yeah, Muay Thai, yeah.
I love it, bro.
Had my first fight recently, which was fun.
Yeah, tell us about that.
How did you do, bro?
Yeah, good, it was, I mean, I've always done Muay Thai,
I've always liked combat sports
and I was like, hey, I've got free time now.
Like, yeah, so I signed up for a fight, super nervous,
but I was like, hey, let's, you know, the fight's signed,
we've got to train hard now, we've got to prepare for war
and, you know, because I had digital landlords,
I had all my money coming in,
I was able to train twice a day,
I was working like an hour or two,
just keeping the lights on and had the fight,
went well, no injuries and got the win.
So that was an awesome moment this year as well.
That's crazy, I love that, dude.
Yeah, there was a student that we had on,
his name is, I think it's Jordan,
and I remember something that he said,
we were talking about, he was talking about
some of the stuff he wants to do with his son and stuff
and he was talking about this mountain
that he wants to climb
and he said something that always stuck with me,
he's like, imagine like living your whole life
and not having, not climbing that mountain
and he named this specific mountain
and I can't remember what mountain it was,
but like that was an important mountain for him.
And it's just insane that like,
there's so many things to do,
so many places to see,
so many like problems to solve,
people to meet, experiences to have,
foods to taste, cultures to experience
and all it is is on the other side
of like just doing the freaking boring work
of what we have in front of us.
It's, I mean, you're an example of it, bro.
What like, what was your life like 27 months ago?
The trenches, I was working 40 hours a week.
I was working two hours after work on the business,
on the side business, on the hobby, you know, at the time.
I was training an hour a day in the gym,
so I was flat out, I only had Sundays off just to recover
and then we'd be straight back in the trenches
and like those are the points I look back on
and kind of like revere and like whole daily,
like sitting at the desk,
like looking out the window and like,
sitting at the desk and looking out the window,
just like dreaming of just an absolute trenches
but like enjoying it, like, you know,
knowing that it was gonna work out
because all of the work that,
all of the mindset stuff and think and grow rich,
that's such a massive part of it.
And especially it is hard at the start
when you don't have that mindset
or you don't have other people around you who are doing it.
But I think just listen to your advice
and jumping on the live calls and just like embracing it.
Look at there in the end.
I think going back to what we talked about
with like discomfort,
you know, one way I've found to make yourself uncomfortable
is purposely putting yourself around people
that are playing at such a higher level than you.
That you will feel uncomfortable
because you know, you're gonna see that like
for them to go and buy a brand new Range Rover
or a brand new G wagon tomorrow cash is an afterthought
or to book a charter, a jet to go down to Mexico
for three days and spend 20 grand is just something
that you decide to do over a drink one night.
And you're like, oh my gosh,
if I'm gonna keep being friends with these people,
I gotta start being like playing a different game
because if I get invited to these things,
I can't be the guy that's like,
dude, what's the price of the jet?
You know what I mean?
So I think one thing that we can do
to force that discomfort is get around people
at a higher level of very, a much higher level than us.
And it makes us, it kind of makes us realize
just how small we're playing compared to other people.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Yeah, a hundred percent.
I mean, eight to 10 weeks after joining your landlords,
I was on around 10K a month.
And I was cruising on about 10K a month for about a year,
like traveling around a bit.
And it got pretty lonely just traveling by yourself.
So I joined like a bit of a network
of like other entrepreneurs.
And like Nick says, like a lot of them
were making some great money,
like much more than myself.
And just being around them,
like pulling you up to a higher level,
or like you're absorbing the mindsets that they have,
like you're thinking about what they're doing.
And that was actually a key part
because at the start of this year
is when I joined that group,
when I was on 10K and then fast forward,
nine months later, we're on 40,000.
So I attribute most of this year's success
to almost all of it, to that group of people.
And even the converse, and I agree, bro.
And even the conversations,
the way that they talk about things,
like I've recently kind of like formed this relationship
with this guy and it's like, just the,
it's like casually like, oh, I'm gonna buy a house.
This guy in Dubai, you know, I think I'm gonna,
he has, I don't know,
I think it's like 14 places here in Dubai.
And he just wanted to buy a villa.
And he wanted to buy a villa.
And there wasn't a budget.
It was just what's the villa that we want.
And I started like to dig in a little bit.
And it was like, and he ended up getting one.
And it was like, it was like 6 million or 7 million.
It was just cash, no loan, no nothing.
And you're like, okay, that's cool, man.
I like, it's just, it's the game is levels.
And you just start going, oh my gosh,
this guy's so much more,
he's doing so much more than me financially.
I gotta keep up.
So anyway, for those of you that are sitting there
going, I feel comfortable.
And I don't know what to do
because I'm making $15,000 a month.
Guys, that is a lot compared to, you know,
your brother that works at Starbucks.
That's great.
But like 15,000 a month,
I don't know how people live on 15,000 a month
that have a family.
And I don't mean that being at all condescending.
I'm genuinely saying like when you look at gas
and if you have a pool and you're paying to heat the pool
and the pool guy and the vacation,
I mean, dude, you can't live on 15.
I don't know how you live on 15 grand.
And I know people that are living on like four grand.
So those of you that are uncomfortable,
one thing that you could try
is getting around other people
than your same friends that you go and, you know,
do, you know, whatever drink on,
at the bowling alley on a Wednesday, whatever.
So, okay, two more questions for me,
three more questions.
And then I wanna go to Q&A.
Mike, these are just random.
And I wanna know this because I swear to you,
I'm trying to like,
I'm asking everybody these questions.
And so they're really kind of out there,
but I'm just, I'm curious.
And there's no wrong answer.
There's no right answer.
But it just, I'm gonna keep asking these questions
because I'm trying to find commonalities.
But are you a spiritual and or religious person
or would you consider yourself neither of those things?
Yeah, definitely.
And open to religion.
I think agnostic's the word.
Definitely believe in some sort of high purpose
or something, you know,
that we can't quite perceive in the third dimension,
whatever that means.
Okay, I just, I'm completely just curious.
Yeah, there's no, it's just, I'm observing,
I'm looking at other things because, you know,
you see things, you're like, oh yeah,
all the people I know that are successful,
they do these, but these are things that are like,
I'm just curious.
Other thing I'm curious about is,
do you, are you actively involved with your time
or money in any kind of like a charity at this point,
or is it something that you plan on doing in the future
or is it just like not something on your radar
that doesn't make you a good or bad person?
I'm just curious.
I don't have any charities,
but I always tip like very, very heavily.
Excuse me.
You know, especially at the villa,
like you've got people cleaning the pool,
people are coming through like plan maintenance,
people come clean and like,
I always tip like, you know, a really good amount.
That's cool.
And that's not only to kind of give back to people
with less opportunity,
but also just building like an abundance mindset
when it comes to money.
And it's funny how it works
is when you start tipping more and like giving more,
you know, deals just landed on your lap,
money is just comes to you.
And yeah, I think that's a charity
in whatever sense it is, it's really good.
You can't be stingy or you can't be scarce with money
because you maintain that reality if it is in your mind.
You know, it's funny.
You guys, I don't know, maybe you do, maybe you don't,
but the guy that does all of our YouTube videos,
he's also a student inside here named Isaac.
He's 21, 22, I think, maybe he's 22, maybe he's 23.
I don't know, he's young.
He taught me something and it pisses me off
that I had to learn this from him
because I always just, I kind of treat him
like little brother, you know, I would kind of rough him up.
But this one day we went to this gym,
we were down in California and we went to this gym,
like we did like a late gym session
because we went to Disneyland and he'd never been
and my family went and I invited him,
went to Disneyland and me and him decided
to go to the gym at like 11.
And he went and bought like a energy drink before the gym
because we were so tired, he bought like a whatever.
And you know, when you buy something
or you go to a restaurant, asks for a tip, right?
He tipped more than the drink.
It was like a $4 drink and he tipped or the same.
It's like five bucks, he tipped five.
And dude, he came over and he was like,
he told me about it, he's like,
you should have seen how happy this guy was.
He was like, thank you so much, bro.
And this kid, I'm like, what?
Why would you tip the, he didn't do anything for you, bro.
Why would you tip on that?
Because I always used to get pissed
when it would be like, you know, do you tip?
And he taught me that he's like,
dude, I always choose the most.
And I'm like, you're stupid, dude.
And I was like, all right, I'm gonna try to do that.
And I swear to you for a long time, I've been doing this.
If I'm on my DoorDash or like in Dubai,
it's called Deliveroo or if I'm at a restaurant,
I always choose the highest amount.
Like if it's like five, seven or 20,
I choose 20 every time.
And I swear sometimes I hesitate cause I'm like,
oh, that's like, especially if it's like $500 bill,
you're like, I just spent an extra whatever, 100 bucks.
I swear to you, there's something about it though,
that if you are, you know, abundant,
then abundance flows to you.
It's crazy.
It's, I don't know.
I don't know how to explain it.
It's like when you go to his tech to the 20 bucks,
for example, like when you go through with it,
it's, you're basically telling yourself,
I know I'm implausible because I know more money's coming.
And that's, that changes the whole way you operate.
When you're on sales call, it's like you're more relaxed.
When you're doing your due diligence,
you're more motivated.
And just touching with the DoorDash,
on the DoorDash, we have Grab here in Thailand.
And this dude rocked up a couple of days ago,
delivering the morning coffee.
He's like freshly broke his hand.
You know, and he's driving his bike.
He gets off his bike and he hands me the coffee.
And I'm like, whoa, this is a poor fellow right here.
And he's still in the trenches, you know, grinding.
And then he came back another week later.
I tipped him 20 bucks, like the max I could in the app.
Then he came back the next week
and he showed me his doctor's certificate.
And I was like, man,
there's some really unfortunate people,
but this guy's still out here, like, you know,
putting food on his family's table.
It's in the way that, yeah, anyway, it's so true, bro.
So anyway, you guys don't have to do that.
But for me, I found that it's like a big thing.
So kind of out there a bit, but it's true.
So, okay, dude, let's get into some Q&A.
I'm gonna ask this last question
and I'm gonna have Aaron kind of like,
be the person that kind of coordinates all the Q&A,
so I don't have to look at it.
But the question that I'm having coming into this,
and I'm just gonna ask it to you
because it's the question I'm trying to like,
think of the, I'm thinking about this the entire time
and this is why I wanted you on this call.
But like, how can we help students in this program
inside of this group replicate your success?
Is it something that we can do,
like my team, me, Aaron, Ashley, Isaac,
and I'm sure it's a combination of both,
and if so, what?
Is it on the students, like how,
dude, what can we, I wish I just knew the answer
and we could do that thing.
I'm trying to extract like how in the world
do we get people to have even a quarter of your success
to just go and do it because there's no reason,
if Mike's at 40,000 in two years per month, US,
why do you guys, why do some of you not have a deal?
I don't get it, I don't get it.
So Mike, how do we replicate your success, dude?
Yeah, I think everything's, I think everything's there,
like, you know, I did a bit of marketing before I joined
and I was going through the course
with like a beginner's mindset
and just following everything exactly as training suggested
and I think the training's perfect.
You know, you follow it enough times,
you're gonna get deals.
I think a big part of the training
that maybe people neglect in place of the technical stuff
like the SCR and due diligence is just the mindset side,
the think and grow rich book that you recommended
and some of the goal setting, you know,
like how many cold calls are you gonna have to do
to hit your $5,000 a month target
or whatever your target is?
And if you don't have your target,
then you need to set a target.
And when you mentioned Tim Ferriss's for our work week,
the first chapter of that is D for definition,
which is to actually define your ideal life
and you might be surprised at how many deals you need.
You only need, you may only need two,
I only need one or two deals
to live my dream life at the start
because that was the price of three meals, a scooter,
you know, a cheap villa in Thailand.
So that's what I would suggest.
I love that.
And just so everybody knows,
we know that we can make improvements
and Aaron kind of alluded to that at the beginning.
There are some massive, we're gonna be,
by the way, we are in the planning stages of redoing
to version 3.0, the training.
And without giving too much away,
we have some really, really interesting stuff.
So just know that we know that like we can improve.
It's not like there's not things that we can do better.
The fact of the matter is though,
that with the exact same training
that is currently available,
Mike has managed to get to $40,000 USD per month
while also fighting and training for a fight,
while also riding his scooter to the beach every day,
while also getting head massages
while he's checking his stride.
Let's not forget about that.
So anyway, bro.
Dude, it's been-
Send the picture for the group.
Yeah, send that picture.
You should post that picture, by the way.
That's an epic.
I saw that on your story and I was like,
I love that story.
That's a really good story you posted.
So I wanna get into a little bit of Q&A,
but I do just wanna first before we go in the last 10 minutes,
just thank you for coming on
because I know your time is super valuable.
$40,000 per month, guys, his time is worth a lot.
And so I hope you guys listen to what he's saying.
And I've heard you say a couple of things.
You've repeated a couple of things,
which I've made a note of here.
And you've inspired me to go and reread Think and Grow Rich
for the third or fourth time,
even though I was probably the one that tried to get you
to do it in the beginning when you watched the training.
But you've mentioned that a couple of times,
which has got me thinking, you know what?
I really should dig back into that.
What a powerful book.
So I hope you guys are listening to Mike.
He is somebody, if you guys are not at $40,000,
you should be thinking, what is this guy doing
that I'm not doing?
Or what is he, as Hermosy always talks about,
what is he not doing that I am doing?
And go do that.
It's extremely simple.
Yeah, that's a huge part of getting from the 10 to the 40
and beyond is, what are you not doing?
Like you say, in the YouTube videos,
it's simplification, just focusing on ranking rent only.
Say no to everything else at the right time.
And focusing on the one thing is how you're gonna really
scale this business.
And to be honest, like today I worked a couple of hours.
I've got 38 active retainers.
And I literally got not much to do.
It's all systematized.
That's because I'm focusing on one thing.
Beautiful, bro.
It's beautiful.
Get good at one thing.
Get good at doing a thousand dollar a month
flat fee Legion deal in four or five niches
and doing it again and again and again and again and again.
And you're gonna get rich.
That's it.
So Aaron, let's bust a couple of questions for Mike
if there's any in the chat.
Yeah, we got some good ones.
So Daniel said, Mike, if you had to restart,
how fast would you get back to 40K?
So assuming like knowing now what you know,
like how fast you think you could scale or?
At the moment, I've probably got about five active deals
in my pipeline, my hair table.
So I'm probably closing a new retainer every week.
So about 40 weeks, I'd get back to 40K.
Yeah, that's awesome.
And I would probably add that Mike would probably do that
while maintaining the exact same lifestyle
that he's got right now.
I'm seeing everything systematized.
If you're only around 10K and you're looking to get to 40K,
I definitely recommend a good book.
It's called Systemology.
I've never really been like a super organized guy,
but Systemology has made systematizing the business
like extremely easy.
I recommend that to everyone.
Beautiful, I'm gonna write that down.
Awesome, I'll put that, cool, I'll put that in the chat.
Yeah, and then Kirk Clark says,
and then Kirk Clark says, where are your customers?
Is it U.S. or is it Australia?
Yeah, so all my customers,
pretty much all my clients are in New Zealand.
I've got two in Australia,
and the time difference is about five hours.
So I still wake up at 10 a.m. my time,
which is like five o'clock in New Zealand,
but we're the ones sitting on digital gold,
so that'd be good fun.
But I thought you couldn't do this outside the U.S.
So you have most of your clients in New Zealand,
not Australia, right?
Because you're from New Zealand.
Yeah, dude.
Yeah, weird.
I didn't know you could do this in other countries.
Weird.
Just kidding.
I honestly didn't know that New Zealand was such a market.
That's awesome.
That's great.
I thought it was just like, honestly,
me and the Australian in the U.S., but that's great.
That's sick, dude.
That's sick.
Keep going.
Jerry says, how is your week slash month structured
for achieving those 40K?
What are the crucial tasks you do to progress that fast?
And he says, by the way,
I've got pretty similar goal in mind
with the Muay Thai mastery,
whatever combat sports you're in.
You're really inspiring.
Thanks for the nuggets you dropped so far.
So I guess kind of how you structure to move the needle.
Yes, we do.
Thanks for the compliment on inspiration.
In terms of moving the needle,
I honestly don't have too much structure in my business.
Like my whole mindset is just wake up
and like get in the trenches basically,
but that being said, where I'm at now with the business,
what actually got me from 10 to 40 was,
what does 40K and Mike do?
What does 40K and Mike do?
And I literally embodied that at the start of the year
while everyone was partying for New Year's.
I was reading books on productivity
and it took nine months to catch up with the actions
in terms of hitting the 40K a month goal.
Some key parts of that were also getting my CRM dialed in.
So I've got to thank Ben Van Harten in the group.
He's actually in digital business in Thailand.
So getting your CRM sorted,
that's extremely important.
Getting your lead reporting sorted,
getting some sort of system to look at your prospecting deals
and obviously how many leads your current clients are getting.
And I'm going to thank Ryan Dalton.
He's actually an integral part of the business
in terms of outsourcing some of my web builds
and also his RankinRent engine system.
I wouldn't be here without that.
Beautiful.
And as a teaser,
the version 2.0 of Ryan's RankinRent engine
is very close to being completed.
So more to come on that.
Anyway, keep going.
Yeah, we got some really good comments here.
I'll just mainly go to the questions,
but we got some really cool comments
and a lot of people appreciate what you're saying, Mike.
So thanks a lot for hopping on.
Matthew, he kind of has like a similar question.
He says, yeah, like, what do you do?
What does your week look like in terms of delegating tasks
for grabbing deals?
And I mean, I guess I can just say,
probably put in the way you got to 40K
was by selling $40,000 worth of deals.
So obviously that sales part.
So I'll personally ask, like,
do you still do the closing calls
and like, have you outsourced everything
about the sales or?
So the only thing I'm outsourcing at the moment
is the SEO builds, the SEO website builds.
And I've got a guy that does all my blogging
and I think he employs his cousins in the Philippines.
So yeah, I mean, I'm on 40,000 USD a month
and I don't have a big team.
I haven't got a huge bill of people that I have to pay.
The profit margins are pretty good.
I've got my Google ads bill and then I've got maybe
three to $4,000 of blog post costs
and outsourcing to Ryan's team.
And in six months, those costs,
the profit margins are gonna be even bigger.
So yeah, I'm pretty proud of the fact
that I only have one person that I really outsource to
and the rest is just on autopilot.
So are you still handling all the sales yourself,
like the prospecting and the setup and the close?
Yeah, so I still do all the sales calls.
Yeah, pretty much.
People, the way I do my prospecting
is I actually get people coming to me now
just through my Instagram profile.
But yeah, we'll see if I need to employ some more people
to get to $66,000 in a month.
But I think the way that everything's set up
and systematized and automated,
I think I'll be able to get to $66,000
without having to figure out building a team,
more of a team.
That's awesome, bro.
We got just like one more question.
Nathan, guys, he put in the link to the book.
So thank you for that for systematology, systemology.
Oh, we got two quick questions
and then you can just fire these.
So Jared said, is your technical SEO team
in Thailand with you?
So it sounds like you just got that one guy.
Yeah, so we're a team in the Philippines.
Just one guy doing the blogs with his cousins
and a bit of WordPress work.
Cool, so that's the other.
Did you get them?
Oh, sorry, I was gonna say,
did you get them on onlinejobs.ph
or where'd you find that guy?
Yeah, onlinejobs.ph.
I've been with him for eight months.
He's amazing.
I definitely recommend onlinejobs.ph
for outsourcing really respectful people
with good English and if you treat them well,
they treat you well.
That's awesome, man.
Yeah, we just got one more question.
Nathan says, and I know this depends on
if you ask this question now,
or like you said, in six months,
once a lot of your sites rank,
but how much of the 40K per month is profit?
Just about.
About 60, 65%.
Wow, that's awesome.
Yeah, I'm ranking these sites really fast
thanks to Ryan's team,
and the way they set everything up.
So I'm able to like reduce the ad spins pretty quickly.
And guys, just to add to that real quick,
if Mike were to take everything in-house
and do it all himself and be a solopreneur,
apart from the ad costs that he has,
I bet he would be closer to 70, 72, 75% profit margin,
but he's doing exactly what I did,
which is he's building out a team.
He's got people doing content.
He's scaling it,
and he's also got an incredible lifestyle.
So you can do this as much,
like he's doing it smart.
So yeah, he's got a 55% profit.
Let's say he's bringing in, what is it?
22, $23,000 in his pocket every single month,
quarter million bucks.
That's his money,
but he doesn't have to do jack shit.
That's why he's fighting Muay Thai fights, right?
And that's the beauty of the entire thing.
Some of you guys are so scared to get somebody
because, oh, I'm gonna have a recurring cost,
and I gotta, good, just go replace it.
Your content person right now,
I'm sure you, I don't know, maybe,
how long have you had that person?
He's had eight months.
So you've had them since the time
you were probably at 25,000,
and you probably added one or two of his cousins,
but you guys, we're trying to scale this thing.
We're not just trying to keep every dollar in our pocket
and do all the work.
It's a lifestyle as well.
50%, and let's look at my 38 current deals.
Let's say it's about a 60 or a 55% profit margin.
Those same 37 clients in a year's time,
I can guarantee they're gonna be 95% profit margin.
So I'm investing and taking over the Google board
and getting these sites,
just printing money every week on all their partners.
By the way.
I put in the work, ranking them.
I love that you call it the Google board.
I heard that on one of your videos
and I was like, I like that.
It sounds like it's like an interesting way
to say it, the Google board.
The monopoly board.
I'm still running the same sales script,
telling them it's the monopoly board and they love it.
I know exactly what you mean.
I just have never heard it called the Google board
and it makes total sense,
and it's kind of a fun way to say it.
So anyway, just kind of just a side note.
Mike, dude, I have so many more questions,
but we don't have time.
I'm gonna send you some voice notes on WhatsApp
about some stuff.
But dude, more than anything,
I think obviously kudos to you because you did the work.
You make the program and us look good,
but I do appreciate you coming on, bro.
I hope you know that.
And everybody please give Mike a thanks for jumping on
and spending his time.
Dude, when are you gonna hit?
What's the goal to hit the 50?
Like, so a thousand, you're doing about a deal a week.
So what, in about 90 days, roughly?
Yeah, I want to get to a hundred thousand New Zealand dollars
where we'll get there.
And I think that's about 66,000 USD.
And I think after that,
I'm just gonna be focusing a bit more on
traveling more around the world
and getting a bit more systematization done.
I love that, bro.
Unbelievable.
It's unbelievable that we, I don't know.
Do you ever get this way sometimes you wake up
and you're like, dude, I'm literally selling air.
Like you guys have seen the Lorax, right?
Have you guys seen the Lorax, that movie?
Yeah, a while back.
You don't have to, if you haven't,
but you should watch it.
It's hilarious.
A Dr. Seuss movie.
And the guy, that little short guy,
the something O'Hare, I don't know his first name.
He's a little short guy with the most amazing haircut.
He sells air.
Like he's literally like polluting the air
and selling it back to him.
But I always am like, dude,
I swear it's like we're selling air.
Like we're just giving these people the,
but it's also a valuable service because
like you could argue, well, if you didn't do this,
then they would get, no, they wouldn't get the leads.
The leads would go to the home advisors
and the Angie's list and the big guys.
We're fighting between the little guys.
So no, just because we're in there
doesn't mean those leads would go to them.
That's not true at all.
We're taking the leads from the big guys.
We're partnering with the little guys
and we're helping them do business.
So I joke about us selling air
because it feels like we're cheating,
but we're offering something that's so valuable
that it's changes these businesses entirely.
So anyway, Mike, thanks for jumping on, bro.
It's my fault in that way.
Yeah, it doesn't seem like it's real business sometimes
when you're just looking at these Stripe accounts
for the green ticks coming in
and you're getting the head massage.
But I've got some feedback recently
from some guys in New Zealand
that their businesses were gonna go under.
Like they were literally gonna have to close down
their shops and I get messages saying,
hey, like we're on a pretty grim spot.
You've literally saved us.
We're now at a point
where we could be taking on more people.
So like we usually are changing people's lives.
So it's a beautiful business model
in pretty much every way possible.
It's dope, dude.
I love it.
Awesome, thanks for jumping on.
And Aaron, thank you as well, brother.
Thanks, guys.
Cheers.
Talk to you soon, guys.
See you, bye.